welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
furiosa trailer the spin-off sequel to
my favorite movie of 2015 Mad Max Fury
Road a film that I recently Dove deep
into for the Deep dive Channel this is
the fifth film of George Miller's Mad
Max franchise with Anya Taylor Joy
playing a younger version of Charlie
sarin's imperator furiosa this film is
coming May 24th 2024 and this trailer
rocks so let's break it down for all the
details that you might have missed by
the way if you are seeing less of me on
the channel this month it's because I am
on paternity leave my baby might be
arriving a bit sooner than expected and
Jessica Clemens is back to cover for me
huge thanks to Jessica and to everybody
on the new rock star team who you are
also going to be seen popping up in
videos in the coming weeks I'm going to
be back fulltime in a few weeks but I am
so excited to watch all their videos
with baby boss okay this film's official
description is as the world Falls young
furiosa is snatched from the green place
of many mothers and into the hands of a
biker hor led by the warlord dementus
while two tyrants wor for dominance over
the Citadel furiosa survives many trials
as she plots away back home through the
Wasteland so if you remember a prologue
to madmax Fury Road included a few sound
bites in the world as it was falling
apart the men Waring over guzzling the
women explaining that it's actually a
water shortage we might see some of that
history but I really think the world
will be a bit further along in this
movie this prequel is going to be set
after Beyond Thunderdome but just before
the time of the four-part greel comic
that was written by George Miller and
Nikola thoris who together scripted Fury
Road and furiosa along with Mark ston
who worked on this comic series and this
comic is considered canonical for the
film storyline since George Miller was
involved the a pretty interesting read
it shows the Back stories of Nu and a
[__] Joe and furiosa as she meets the
wives and of course the backstory of Max
right before Fury Road so the two
tyrants in this movie are likely going
to be immortan Joe formerly known as
Colonel joeore who is a war veteran who
forms a gang of Raiders as society's
collapsing and the other Tyrant being
Chris hord's character but I think we're
going to see the big aquafer battle that
aquafer will later become The Citadel in
Fury Road and Joe's violent sacrificing
of his followers yet his survival will
be how Joe gains the moniker of immortan
after he takes over over the aquafer Joe
Awards the Batman who told him about
this aquafer charge of an oil refinery
that they later call gas town and that
guy becomes the people leader and he
gives a mine that they find to his
wartime follower major Kalashnikov aka
the bullet farmer and that mine becomes
the bullet farm this Prelude comic
details how Joe brought in furiosa to be
an imperator to guard his wives
including the splendid and Karen the dag
toast The Knowing Cheeto the fragile and
capable in Fury Road we learned that
furiosa came from a female dominated
society called the many mothers aka the
balini one pretty dark de detail about
the many mothers is that any males that
were born to this tribe were banished to
the swamps on the borders of the green
place and they became the crow Fishers
that we see walking on stilts and the
many mothers would do raids on those
male Crow Fishers to steal their sperm
so that the balini could reproduce it
was kind of implied that this was part
of the original sin that haunts furiosa
in Fury Road and it's what might have
spiritually cursed the many mothers into
losing their green Place yeah George
Miller's mythology for the madmax
universe is incredibly complex and
evolved over the course of years as he
prev visualized every frame of Fury Road
with his storyboard artists but the real
hero of this film was his wife Margaret
sixel who edited Fury Road a gargantuan
task that worked so well because these
spouses were so in sync and Miller would
frame every shot so that the point of
focus was in the center of the shot so
Margaret could later rrap it cut from
point of focus to point of focus and the
viewer's eyes would not have to struggle
to readjust in this movie Chris
Hemsworth plays dementus the warlord of
the biker horde who kidnaps fosa from
the many mothers Tom Burke joins a cast
in a role originally cast as Yaya Abdul
matin who had to lead due to scheduling
conflict Nathan Jones returns from Fury
Road as a Morton Joe's muscular but
dimwitted son rusus yes that is his real
name and Anga Samson also returns as the
organic mechanic AKA The Doctor Who's
given the name mechanic because yes this
is a car worshipping culture before the
trailer dropped attendees at ccxp were
shown this glorious looking gold covered
Ona Taylor joy as furiosa you can make
out an earlier version of her prosthetic
mechanical arm as well as this belt
buckle this is the same belt buckle that
has the Morton Joe sigil worn by him and
all of his sons that has the flaming
skull steering wheel with chain mail
hanging beneath which mirrors the way
water gushes out of the Citadel aquafer
from the skull mouth now the new trailer
footage opens in the dust titles cast in
The Shadow on that dust from Mastermind
George Miller and the black and white
transitions into heavily saturated
orange and blue that we remember from
the 2015 film Miller's colorists in that
movie went heavy on the New South Wales
landscape because you know dystopia
movies typically desaturate their color
palettes looking at you Book of Eli and
yeah it it does make this movie look
like a larger than life story book type
of story and I think that's okay I think
people are being way too hard on the CGI
of this trailer you forget that a lot of
the 2015 movie was CGI and we were okay
with it then I don't know I'm someone
who looks at movie trailers for a living
and I don't understand how a lot of
people's like knee-jerk hot take is CGI
looks bad like are all of you CGI
experts like did all of you go to some
CGI school that I didn't go to but I
love the composition of this shot with
furiosa trudging out toward their
Horizon looking like that iconic shot of
her the moment of defeat in Fury Road
when she realized that the green place
was gone also her wide stance also looks
like Max when he was first looking out
at the flats in the opening shot of Fury
Road when he was to the right of his
Interceptor ironically it's the voice of
one of the many mothers that's ringing
in her mind now begging her to promise
to come home to them a promise that she
will long to keep right up until that
moment in Fury Road the rock formations
in the distance kind of look like the
Citadel that would be Joe's aquafer the
way furiosa turns around to the camera
as she's looking down the road also kind
of looks like the opening shot of Max
rockatansky in Fury Road when he's
eating that two-headed lizard looking
completely feral we see dementus his
biker horde plowing ahead and in the
center of it dementus A six- Wheel
monster truck George Miller said at ccxp
that dementus will begin this movie in a
chariot pulled by motorbikes kind of
like horses and we do see that later in
the trailer titles fly out at us from
that median Horizon 45 years after the
collapse a young furiosa is taken from
her family she will devote the rest of
her life to finding her way back home
this is her Odyssey 45 years after the
collapse interesting the CCX panel also
said that this will be 15 years before
Fury Road look the first Mad Max takes
place as the world is collapsing and
then Road Warrior and Beyond Thunderdome
take place in the years after the
nuclear war but hey even in Fury Road
Max should have been way older than Tom
Hardy looked in that movie so really it
was like back in 2015 when George Miller
just kind of let go of the exact
timeline continuity I think we should
just look at Fury Road in the Prelude
comics of Fury Road as kind of a reset
point now the word Odyssey is very
interesting to me Odyssey is obviously a
common term now for any character going
on a long circular Journey on a vessel
of sorts meeting Argonauts and beasts
along the way but the word Odyssey has
of course its roots in Homer's Odyssey
the story of a dis
as he made his way home to his wife
Penelope after the Trojan War and got
into all kinds of high Jinks but I think
it's interesting that we know furiosa's
fate is to lose her home of the green
place so really we can view the Final
Act of Fury Road as odys slaying all the
Penelope suitors an anticlimax scouring
of the Shire and the taking over of the
Citadel was her true homecoming she
finds a new home Chris Hemsworth barely
recognizable in this movie other than
his physique since he's behind a waxed
mustache and a prosthetic nose he says
into the mic lady
and yes lady singular one lady now
dementus looks younger here than other
times we see him in the trailer so this
must be a bit in the past and I actually
think the captive girl is Young furiosa
after she was captured from the green
place and the writer with this
interesting skull mask with a padlock is
some other Rogue Rider who inspired
furiosa we see a sandstorm looming up
behind the Rogue Rider and this riter
later in the trailer is completely on
fire as she's rescuing young fosa this
could be how fosa got the idea to call
herself furiosa one of the furies and
she isn't afraid to steer into a
sandstorm but furiosa is going to lose
this bear to dementus and she's probably
also going to lose an arm and a
promotional still shows a wider shot of
dementus where he has his stuffed bear
strapped to his waist and in fact later
in the trailer we do see that bear
around his midsection he also wears what
looks like a marching band vest yes it's
all very eclectic and very scrapped
together as always we see a shot of the
war boys beside this huge shiny Chrome
rig I don't think this is furiosa's war
rig or at least not yet I think it's
just a different rig but it has this
crazy engraving of imort Joe
romanticized as this muscular God figure
towering over the lowly and then we see
dementus with that prosthetic nose very
clearly made to look like it would had
been broken in the past faces off
against imort and Joe now H's burn
played imort Joe in the 2015 Fury Road
film this is a new actor he was getting
up there but because the makeup and The
Mask are so iconic really you could put
a number of different people in that
thank you to geology for partnering with
us to bring you this video and also for
giving our audiences exclusive access to
their new try before you buy program
you've probably heard me mention geology
before the 28 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recogniz in
men's health hype Beast birdie Esquire
ask men and Oprah daily grooming Awards
but hey I get it it can be tough to
change a skincare routine or start a new
one part of what's nice about giy is
they create simple and effective
skincare and Hair Care routines
customized just for you and now if you
want to try that new routine out before
you buy a bunch of stuff you can geology
is offering new rockstars viewers a free
trial of their eight piece skincare set
with their try before you buy program
you can experience a new skincare
routine risk-free for 14 days if you
don't love it send it back it's that
easy the set is valued at $139 all you
pay today is the price of shipping and
if you order today get a free vitamin C
plus e fuic acid as a gift you don't
need to return it that's yours just head
to geology.com neww rockstars and get
your free trial and geology will send
you a personalized skincare routine and
if you don't mind me I'm going to take
some geology and uh uh look good for the
rest of this video a biker throws a
spear into the back of Joe's rig and
notice how four maces are hanging for
the back of the rig and based on the
Machinery they hang from these Maes spin
360° to keep Raiders from sneaking up
behind them and kind of create like a
deadly shield for anyone trying to creep
up we actually see this in action later
on in the trailer and for the shot I
just love how George Miller keeps the
camera close to the ground so that the
dust is like kicking up in our face so
in the 2015 film George Miller was very
much inspired by classic John Ford
Western's like stage coach and if you
watch the Sten Spielberg movie The fabl
you know John Ford one snapped at a
young Stevie Spielberg giving him advice
about shot composition about Horizon
Lines in the frame David Lynch played
John for to that scene and I just always
love this he goes if it's at the bottom
of the frame it's interesting if it's at
the top of the frame it's interesting if
it's in the middle it looks like [__]
and get the [__] out of my office and of
course where's the Horizon in the shot
it's at the bottom fosa smears some axle
grease on her forehead starting to take
the appearance of her adult form when it
just completely coats her head and
notice how behind her is the Morton
Joe's steering wheel alter that we see
the war boys grab the wheels from and
then they prey before they head out then
a crazy shot of a bunch of bullet shells
gushing down on dementus as he hangs
from this platform over a fiery Chasm
I'm going to assume this is at the
bullet Farm which is a mine that Orton
Joe handed off to Major kalishnikov aka
the bullet farmer and I love how they
put dementus in a cape looking a lot
like Thor of course but also kind of
like a Roman Centurion when later we see
him in the Chariot really this whole
world is just gross little boys playing
dress up then we see a color we don't
often see in this film Universe green
because this is the original Green place
as the many mothers aka the the balini
run with it looks like primitive weapons
like we see machetes some old rifles
they all wear blue and white they carry
cens then I think the shot from this
trailer that has me the most confused
because furiosa is an Embrace with Tom
Burke's character Tom Burke was hired in
this movie to replace Yaya Abdul matin
who had to leave for scheduling reasons
both of them have their feet in this
watery cave Burke here is wearing a
leather jacket and yeah and since he is
third build in this movie I'm pretty
sure this is young Joe in the Prelude
comic before she was an imperator who
guarded the Five Wives furiosa was a
past wife of Joe and since this is why
yeah they must be in the aquifer of the
Citadel here maybe in a kind of creepy
marriage ceremony that he does now the
other two shots of a Morton Joe in this
trailer they're not H's burn they really
do look like Tom Burke Tom Burke played
Orson Wells and David finer M he's an
incredible actor he really does have the
facial structure for the role I just
think it's interesting that he replaced
Yaya Abdul matine II so originally
George Miller's plan for this movie was
to have Yaya play the role of young and
Morton Joe that would have been a crazy
and really cool bold Choice still that's
nothing against Tom Burke he did an
incredible ciane era Orson Wells he know
knows how to play an egomaniac he's
going to crush this but yeah I think
we're seeing the story about how furiosa
will team up with Joe to overthrow
dementus but then furiosa is going to be
left with the tragic guilt for signing
that deal with the devil we get this
crazy jittery zoom in on furiosa goggles
on nose and mouth covered axle grease
all over the forehead similar to the
shots of nuck in Fury Road then a shot
of what I assume is Gast Town that's the
oil refinery that Joe awarded to the
People Eater that's a bald fat guy with
a disgusting cannibalistic backstory
that Fury Road just began to hint at I'm
dreading to see him in this movie Fury
stands alongside other followers of
Morton Joe praising with their V8 symbol
of interlocking fingers to resemble a V8
engine and then an early shot of
dement's biker horde front and center is
this awesome bike with a fan on the back
the rider has a mask with curved horns
dementus rides behind him in his Chariot
there's also a police motorcycle in this
horde that looks like it's from the
original 1979 Mad Max era they're
charging toward Gast town There's a
quick shot of various screaming I diosa
as she looks like she's surrounded by
hordes of people outside of Joe's
Citadel from Joe's rig she fires there's
a harpoon at that driver and dementus
the sword that we saw earlier with the
curved horns and yeah you can see that
his bike is Airborne he's using this fan
to fly and there are ropes suspended
above I'm pretty sure they are floating
from either like a kite or a parachute
or maybe even balloons from behind the
gateo holds a sought off shotgun looks
like a battle set in gas town There's a
different shot where she's firing a
sniper rifle reminding this of furious's
sharp shooting in 2015's Fury Road when
she needed Max to just stop breathing to
steady himself so that she could aim
there's a Refinery column at Gast town
that collapses as a rig over their heads
is just sticking out over the canyon
Edge then we see furiosa's original
mechanical prosthetic arm and it is
gnarly looks like it has like actual
like fingers but maybe just like three
enough with an opposable thumb to grab
stuff there's like the index finger that
has this kind of mesh cover and then
like a middle finger that has like a
hook for like prying things and it's all
controlled by tubes that look like it's
just connected to that shoulder piece
and the closeup after this inside of the
car makes it seem like it's all part
scavenged from a car engine which of
course it would be furiosa in this movie
drives a new vehicle this is an S Series
Valiant sv1 Chrysler these were actually
produced in Australia from 1962 to 1963
and I really like it when these movies
include Australian builds for cards
because a lot of the time we see
American builds but the trailer ends
with furiosa with her hair cut Morton
Joe's belt buckle lowering her mask to
face dementus who asks you have it inion
to might it epic look folks we are
seeing a supercharged dystopia all of
these figures have embraced their
shortened lifespans and lived their
lives on the edge on the extremes they
scream witness they romanticize their
deaths as roads to Valhalla if they have
any Legacy at all it would be a history
that lives on through word Burgers aka
the history men who tattoo historical
passages on their skin the first film
ended with a quote from the first
history man where must we go we who
wander this Wasteland in search of our
better selves by Framing this as
furiosa's Odyssey these films are
presented as kind of an in Universe
mythological epic myth Parables for how
survivors in a post-apocalyptic
landscape should live their lives so
it's not enough for furiosa to just
survive or win the day she has to do it
with style and a spectacular ular way to
become a storyed figure of Legend when
she begins Fury Road she was already a
pretty admired figure with so much
Goodwill and capital in the Citadel that
she could get away with veering off
course for just long enough to get a
head start from Joe's war party every
second of that counted and this is a
story of how she earns that crucial time
please support Instagram and something
from nerd riot. shop also check out the
Deep dive where I did a pretty in-depth
breakdown of Mad Max Fury Road you're
really going to want to watch that
before you go into furiosa next year
I'll be back for my paternity leave in a
few weeks again thanks to Jessica
Clemens and everyone on the new
rockstars team for covering for me and
I'll see you soon
[Music]
bye